ever since harry houdini's 1919 movie
the master mystery
robot stories have run the entire
spectrum of human emotion
we should know that for the purpose of
this list robots can include anything
from mech suits to cyborgs
and the spare parts in between change
your batteries and bring yourself back
online because these are the best robot
movies
of all time set in the 29th century
wally finds a world that's been
devastated by human carelessness
and global warming as a result people
now live on distant spaceships
waiting for the earth to heal the humans
on these massive star liners continue to
be lazy and destructive
relying on machines to carry them around
wally is one of the last cleaning robots
left on earth
he has a simple and joyful life
collecting random objects and drifting
through the desolation
until he meets eve a robot sent to
identify
signs of life
[Music]
[Applause]
wary and eve's relationship is tender
and sweet they fall in love and
eventually find evidence that humans can
finally return to rebuild earth
amazingly many of the robots in wall-e
including eve
display far more empathy compassion and
humanity than most of the humans in the
film james cameron's a terminator was a
groundbreaking robot movie when it came
out in 1984
but his own sequel in 1991 blew the
original out of the water
terminator 2 judgement day featured both
the revamped version of the original
robot played by
arnold schwarzenegger and the t-1000 who
remains one of the most amazing robot
creations
ever put to screen this shape-shifting
robot played by robert patrick has a
base form of liquid metal which is
thrilling to watch in action
the practical and digital effects in
terminator 2 judgement day
are even better now thanks to hd tvs and
the battle between the two robots are
just as epic
it's rare when a sequel surpasses the
original but terminator 2 easily
outperforms the first film ridley
scott's 1979 sci-fi horror film alien
introduced audiences to extraterrestrial
beasts with acid for blood and creepy
face-hugging creatures that impregnate
humans through their mouths
but alien also featured the horrifying
revelation that ash the chief science
officer aboard the nostromo
is actually a robot and worse he's been
given the order to bring back the
xenomorph creature intact
and the crew is totally expendable when
our hero ripley finds out about ash the
robot tries to attack her
but suffers an android meltdown and
loses his head
ash represents the worst of robot nature
where his core code forces him into
terrible acts of violence
in alex garland's disturbing ex machina
we meet caleb
a programmer who has won a vacation to
the remote estate of nathan bateman
his company's ceo more importantly he's
won the unique opportunity to see what
new projects nathan is developing
before anyone else does nathan
introduces caleb to a robot he designed
named ava
hoping she shows signs of consciousness
through their interactions
although ava resembles a machine in
every way other than her face
feet and hands her personality is so
charming that caleb finds himself
falling in love
as caleb loses trust in the brash and
erratic nathan
we learn that ava has plans of her own
plans that exclude both men
the special effects in ex machina are
spectacular and the performances are
remarkable
even though the plot focuses on common
artificial intelligence themes
ex machina is a compelling addition to
the ai canon
hoverhoven's dystopian 1987 action
thriller robocop
is set in a future detroit on the verge
of total collapse
after a shootout leaves officer alex
murphy dead his body is taken into a
pilot program
designed to play cyborg officers in
dangerous parts of the city
the longer alex's robocop however the
more he is haunted by memories of his
former life
and his brutal demise when robocop
realizes that his own boss was
responsible for alex's fall
he goes on a wild rampage for justice in
the film we see the tension between his
human soul and his robot body
by the end our hero must find new ways
to integrate both halves of himself
ultimately the film suggests that human
and machine can co-exist in one body
based on a novel by philip k dick ridley
scott's 1982 cyberpunk masterpiece blade
runner
is a narrative feast featuring sweeping
scenes of an imaginary 2019 the film
introduces us to a group of human-like
robots
known as replicants these robots are
essentially slaves that were designed to
work for humans
what's even worse is that they only live
for four years with such a short shelf
life a group of replicants decides to do
something about it
harrison ford plays decker a human cop
who sets out to destroy the escaped
replicants
along the way he begins to see how human
these beings really are
and depending on which version of blade
runner you've seen his own reality comes
into question
the robots in blade runner are
indistinguishable from humans
unlike many other robot stories where
the inhumanity and physical differences
are highlighted
plus the moving tears in rain speech at
the film's end elevates blade runner to
one of the greatest films of all time
thomas anderson is a low-level
information tech clerk who enjoys
occasionally going down the rabbit hole
as a hacker called neo
when a radical named trinity informs him
that the infamous morpheus can tell him
everything he wants to know about the
matrix
neo jumps at the opportunity but not
before the evil agent smith attempts to
silence neo
and keep him from his destiny the matrix
features some of the more monstrous
robots in sci-fi history
these beings appear as jellyfish-like
creatures with many eyes and tentacles
which is about as far from human as a
robot can look they harvest humans as a
renewable energy source and to keep them
from fighting back
the robots created an elaborate computer
program that convinces people they're
actually in the real world
with its high concept and unique
portrayal of robotic beasts the matrix
stands out as one of the best
robot movies steven spielberg's robot
opus ai artificial intelligence is set
in the 22nd century
where a devastated world is marked by
extreme economic inequality
robots known as mecca were created to
serve all functions
and even show up as surrogate children
for those who can't have kids of their
own
david is one such child but gifted to
monica swinton
after her terminally ill son was forced
into hibernation until a cure is
available
david knows he's a robot but once he
imprints on moniker as her son
he becomes completely attached to his
new mom after monica's real son wakes
from his slumber and returns home
david is flung into the wild world
outside the swinton home
a world where mecca are hunted tortured
and destroyed in a beautiful narrative
that borrows from pinocchio david
searches for the blue fairy so he can
become a real boy
ai is a heartbreaking commentary on what
it means to be human
as told through the eyes of a robot
child horror master guillermo del toro
took a huge leap from his usual affair
with the epic robot battle extravaganza
pacific rim
in the film a deep underwater rift opens
up on earth releasing a set of monsters
known as the kaiju who terrorized the
planet
in retaliation humans create equally
monstrous robots manned by pilots
sent to combat the growing kaiju threat
where pacific rim differs from the other
mecca movies
is that the robots are controlled by
humans as opposed to having their own
consciousness
the robots in pacific rim are simply
human weapons the real
tension arises from pilots rawley
beckett and marco mori
face their own dramatic histories to
properly overcome the kaiju threat
the special effects are wild and the
action never stops
with a story driven by emotional
conflict pacific rim
is easily one of the best robot movies
of all time
based on ireland's novel of the same
name the stepford wives remains one of
the most chilling robot movies of all
time
the movie follows would-be manhattan
photographer joanna eberhardt and her
husband walter
after they moved to a small connecticut
town called stepford
joanna feels stifled by the community
even though it's beautiful
she finds the other women in town
horribly boring and is deeply disturbed
by the local men's association
headed by its creepy president dale
cobra thankfully joanna meets bobby a
vocal feminist who would also love to
dismantle the strange patriarchy
surrounding them
that is until one day bobby starts
acting just like all the other stepford
wives
from there joanna discovers that the men
in town have been replacing the women
with robots
offering commentary on gender marriage
and social control
considering its 1975 release this film
has aged remarkably well
batteries not included is a unique robot
movie that features an elderly couple at
its center
when a greedy manhattan property
developer named lacey tries to take over
a rent-controlled apartment building
managed by frank and faye riley
the rileys and their tenants resist for
as long as they can
one night after lacy's goons damage the
building a flying robot creature known
as a fix-it appears the fixes repair all
the damage
as well as other structural problems in
the building in a fascinating term for a
robot movie
mama and papa fix it actually have a set
of babies and by the end of the film
there's a rather large community of
fixit robots residing in new york
set in 2020 where robot fighting has
replaced boxing
charlie kenton is a former prize fighter
whose pivot to robot boxing has been
rocky
with his brash personality charlie finds
himself deeper in debt and without a
robot to bet on
well that is until he finds out his
ex-girlfriend's past and his son max is
now involved in a custody dispute
between his aunt deborah and her wealthy
husband
marvin seeing an opportunity charlie
extorts marvin for 50 000
so he can buy a classic boxing robot he
also gets stuck with max for the summer
he was cut from much of the same cloth
as his estranged father
max is into robot boxing as well and
turns out to be a huge help to charlie
especially after discovering a junkyard
robot named atom
the movie features incredible fight
scenes with an army of actual boxing
robots created using the same technology
that brought jurassic park and avatar to
life there are also absolutely charming
moments where max and atom dance
together real steel is not only one of
the best robot movies of all time
but it also comes wrapped in a
heartwarming story about the intense
bonds between a father
and his son set in 1957 during the
height of american tensions with russia
the iron giant starts with a mysterious
object crashing into the water
near the small and quaint town of
rockwell maine the next day a young
local named hogarth
discovers that the object is in fact an
enormous extraterrestrial robot who is
both friendly and curious about the
planet upon which he landed
due to the political tensions of the
cold war era a xenophobic us agent
is convinced that something far more
sinister is taking place in rockwell
than a robot who's ended up on the wrong
planet
over the course of the film hogarth and
the giant's friendship grow stronger
but their relationship is eventually
challenged by the american government
the giant has an opportunity to prove he
was never a threat to humans
and that people are in fact their own
worst enemies with lush colours and a
powerful story that ends on a hopeful
note the iron giant is one of the most
beautiful robot tales ever told
fritz lang's 1927 masterpiece metropolis
has long been celebrated by film
scholars and fans alike
its story was far ahead of its time and
featured a female robot
who's made to look like a human
anti-capitalist organizer
in a plot by the ruling class who then
ruined her reputation to maintain the
status quo
it's complicated yes metropolis might
require more suspension of disbelief
than other robot films on this list
but the fact that this movie was made in
1927 is pretty impressive
plus it not only features technology
that simply didn't exist at the time but
it also has a very obvious
anti-capitalist message
that remains wildly relevant today check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you